you
Shayne's in order to deliver the
necessary PPE and other medical
equipment to the states Speaker Pelosi
and House Democrats are currently
promoting a three trillion dollar
liberal which lists among a litany of
Democrat priorities and material to the
coronavirus crisis are embedded in this
and one would require the President to
appoint a quote medical supplies
response coordinator who would quote
serve as the point of contact for the
healthcare system supply chain officials
and the states on medical supplies I'm
happy to report this individual already
exists this bill ignores reality because
the medical supplies official is in
existence he's been working on this
since March to deliver to date over
billions and billions in 1 billion I
should say pieces of PPE two countries
and hospitals across the country since
March 29th Rear Admiral John Plouffe
Czech vice director for logistics for
the Joint Chiefs has been on the job as
the head of FEMA's supply chain
stabilization task force this is a
historic partnership with the private
sector and under the leadership of
President Trump FEMA directed the
greatest mobilization of the private
sector since World War two Rear Admiral
pull-up check and FEMA quickly realized
the power of the private sector and
addressing the coronavirus recognizing
that the six largest private sector
medical distributors would have the
ability to source procure manufacture
and deliver as many as 1 billion pieces
of PPE in a single week that is
extraordinary volume by our private
sector and at the direction of President
Trump
ruah Rear Admiral Plouffe check and FEMA
were able to harness this power every
day at 9 a.m.
Rear Admiral pull-up checks team
Huddle's with the six large private
sector medical distributors and together
they review data compiled by dr. Burks
as well as information provided by the
CDC to set priorities and ensure
sufficient levels of supplies go down
not just to the county level but to the
hospital level after focusing
geographically Rear Admiral upchuck and
his team Orient's the data to set point
of care distribution priorities for
public hospitals VA and DOD facilities
private hospitals nursing homes acute
clue
scuse me acute care clinics first
responders and labs in just two and a
half weeks Rear Admiral of check and his
team we're able to combine data streams
utilize supply chain visuals
visualization tools from DoD and input
data into the cloud this system is now
available to generate reports for
governor's showing what their state
received from the federal government and
commercial partners all the way down to
the hospital level as I noted and thanks
to President Trump and his
administration governor's now have
visibility as to where their supplies
are sent and where they're received and
from March 1st through May 10th this
public-private partnership has led to
the delivery these are extraordinary
numbers of over 113 million in 95
respirator masks nearly half a billion
surgical masks nearly 18 million face
shields and over 12 billion gloves that
is a lot of PPE and we thank our private
sector partners for engaging in this
effort with us also I just wanted to
note that earlier today the president
held an hour-long call with thousands of
Hispanic community business and faith
leaders across the country he recognized
the many contributions of the Hispanic
community to our country and addressed
important issues like how to reopen
their businesses and build the greatest
economy and history again and finally
before I take questions I just wanted to
note on a separate note that I wanted to
acknowledge the passing of Ravi
Zacharias a renowned Christian apologist
who left this world yesterday our
prayers are with robbie's family during
this time he meant a lot to a lot of
people around this administration and as
my father said Billy Graham was the
great evangelist and Ravi Zacharias was
the great apologist and we are all
thinking about him and holding him close
to our hearts and his family today and
with that I'll take questions John
Bailey what does the president believe
is illegal about the secretary of state
of Michigan setting up absentee ballot
applications and what federal funding is
he considering withholding from the
state of Michigan as
so you know I won't get into exactly
what the funding considerations are I
would note that his tweets were meant to
alert secretary minuchin and mr. vote
about some head of OMB about his
concerns with trillions of dollars going
to these states and his noted concerns
about a lot of fraud that is potentially
at play when you have mass mail and
voting so with regard to the
illegalities and legality of it that's a
question for the campaign as to their
voting and ballot practices but I would
just note that his tweet was meant to
alert OMB you wanted to be very careful
as we send trillions of dollars to
states that we keep this important point
in mine and we ensure that there's
fairness in our voting system and
absolute accuracy but the President
himself has voted just two months ago by
a mail-in ballot there are several
Republican states they're also doing
these Midland applications for ballots
and so I'm confused what is it that he
thinks is illegal that's happening in
Michigan he doesn't really specify so
first with regard to the president doing
a mail-in vote the president is after
all the president which means he's here
in Washington he's unable to cast his
vote down in Florida his state of
residence so for him that's why he had
to do a mail-in vote but he supports
mail-in voting for a reason when you
have a reason that you are unable to be
present there's right now we're very far
from November 3rd I would I'm glad that
you have the prediction tool and you
could tell us what will be happening on
November 3rd 2020 I certainly don't know
it as the present Ares coming up and
that's like what's happening in Tuvalu
I would also I assume you care about
fairness and accuracy in our elections
do you not there is evidence you can go
look this up on ProPublica there is a
bipartisan consensus on the fact that
mass mail and voting can lead to fraud
there was a 2005 commission by none
other than President Carter who's not a
member of the Republican Party and also
James Baker about this concluding that
these ballots quote remain the largest
source of potential voter fraud so this
is a concern the president's right to
look at this we want a free and fair
election and that's his concern yes he
can we
when the president deleted his first
tweet which alleged ultimately
co-efficient spending on absolutely
balanced every letter in fact they
stepped out absolutely ballot requests
was the president misinformed this
morning
and why is he only directing and
especially for a Michigan not other
states of Georgia millions that are
sending similar absentee ballot requests
to their cities so the president
corrected his tweet as you noted and
with regards to going to state by States
and looking at ballots in the way
they're distributed that would be a
question for the Trump campaign and I'd
refer you to the campaign on that point
the g7 you get any more details on the
tiny way the president would like to
that the schedule at Bueller Washington
and does that mean that travel
restrictions that are currently in place
I'm I'm travel from from Europe in China
in other places would potentially be
relaxed before that meeting would take
place here so I won't get into the
mechanics of how that would happen I
would know that the president really
wants to see the g7 happen here in
Washington as we be again not just to
reopen the country but as the world
begins to reopen um you'd like to see it
happen sometime in June but as to a
particular date I don't have any
announcement on that front or to the
mechanisms of how we'd make that work
there's a couple of questions for you
one this president Trump to support the
CDC guidelines that were released over
the weekend and if so why were they
released so quietly why not talk about
them roll them out here from the podium
so the CDC guidelines there was a 60
page document that came out last night
that I assume you're referencing on that
document I talked I talked to dr.
Redfield earlier today about it and much
of that was already out there so
appendices a B C and D had been out
there for a while appendix e he said he
thinks got posted sometime late last
week and again these were his rough
estimates he was giving me
appendix F was being discussed and there
was constructive criticism of it through
the task force and the interagency
process so that was refined and my point
in sharing that with you is that the 60
page document was merely an aggregation
of a lot of what was already out there
so it's not as if this was new
information that we were announcing but
it was more guidance pursuant to our
reopening of America guidance that was
issued
weeks ago husband support the guidelines
did you think Americans should follow
those guidelines or should they be
following the initial guidelines the
president's been very clear he supports
the reopening of America guidelines the
CDC guidelines are in concert with those
guidelines he wants to safely reopen
this country it's very important we do
so and it's good to see that most states
I think basically all of them have plans
at this point to reopen and we're
starting to see the safe reopening of
several states and Americans getting
back to work we just get your reaction
to something we've gotten moments ago a
statement from the American Nurses
Association which says quote the
American Nurses Association has not
received reports from nurses or other
frontline health care workers utilizing
hydroxychloroquine as a preventive
treatment for kovat 19:00 why does the
president continue to say that many or
thousands of frontline workers are using
it as a prophylactic well there is um at
Henry Ford Hospital is doing a study on
this now or 3,000 frontline workers will
be taking hydroxychloroquine to look at
X use as a prophylaxis I believe there's
a few hundred or 190 workers and Tampa
General Hospital's so this is being used
by by some and one thing I want to note
with regard to hydroxychloroquine
because I think it's very important that
we're as accurate as we can be with our
reporting on this hydroxychloroquine has
been a drug that has been in use for 65
years for lupus arthritis and malaria it
has a very good safety profile but as
with any drug and as with any
prescription it should be given by a
doctor to a patient in that context so
no one should be taking this without a
prescription from their doctor but that
being said I've seen a lot of apoplectic
coverage of hydroxychloroquine you had
Jimmy Kimmel saying the president's
quote trying to kill himself by taking
it you had Joe Scarborough saying quote
this will kill you Neil Cavuto saying
what have you got to lose on one thing
you have to lose our lives and you had
Chris Cuomo saying the president knows
that hydroxychloroquine is not supported
by science he knows it has been flying
flagged by his own people and he's using
it well Cuomo mocked the president for
this and interestingly I found this
just before coming here
hydroxychloroquine of course is an
fda-approved medication with a long
proven track record for safety and it
turns out that Chris Cuomo took a less
safe version of it called quinine which
the FDA removed from the market in 2006
because of its serious side effects
including death so really interesting to
have that criticism of the President on
that note - Chris Cuomo I'd like to
redirect him to his brother the governor
of New York Governor Cuomo who has
several on-the-record statements about
hydroxychloroquine saying I'm an
optimist I'm hopeful about the drug and
that's why we'll try it here in New York
as soon as we get it there has been
anecdotal evidence that it's promising
that's why we're going ahead and I have
about eight other quotes from Governor
Cuomo should any of you have interest in
that studies though there are trials
that are in their early phases do you
any evidence that thousands of frontline
workers are currently using it because
they believe it actually will prevent
them from getting the FDA has approved
this for off-label use you know this
president's a big believer and right to
try legislation people who are in there
lastly there are several studies that
have been brought that the president has
actually mentioned that I'd refer you to
there was one out of France a French
study involving more than a thousand
patients that found that the vast
majority had quote good clinical
outcomes and by the vast majority that
was more than 90 percent there's an
Italian study of more than 65,000
patients that demonstrated only 20
tested positive of those who are taking
at prophylactically in a South Korea
study as well so there are several
studies and if you're someone out there
and this is a safe drug to use and your
doctor importantly to underscore that
and your doctor prescribes it for your
use as a prophylaxis or after coming
into contact with Cova then it's
something you should take if it's
prescribed by the doctor and that's your
personal medical choice yes the governor
the Santas just
that the president may be going down to
Florida for the SpaceX NASA launch next
week is that accurate so we have no news
on scheduling at that front but if I if
I get news in the future I will
certainly provide that for you yes Jeff
Kaylee how often does the president talk
to director vote or acting director vote
from VOA - who - the acting director of
OMB often he just was in the Oval Office
with the president so they do speak
often I don't have a readout of the
president's schedule but they do speak
regularly he wanted to flag to him his
concerns about Michigan why don't he
just tell him instead of sending a tweet
because the president believes an
unprecedent transparency and I'm sure
you as a journalist Tom are very eager
and excited when you learn about the
president's decision-making process in
real time whether that's on Twitter for
me here up at the podiums you just said
that way that was the reasoning for him
but I'm saying this is a transparent
president and I think that that's
something that you should be allotting
rather than questioning as to why he
decided to tweet this president back
wrong do you have any other answers from
g7 leaders that they they are willing
definitely willing to come here so we'll
get into the president's private
conversations and correspondences on
with world leaders but we do hope to see
this happen we hope that how can you
characterize the responses being great
how's a good idea or thinking about it
so I don't have any information about
the response from world leaders but we
certainly hope to see this happen yes
yes thank you could you clarify please
president Trump's comments about saying
that it was a good idea it was good that
there were so many positive tests for
for a cope of 19 whereas a lot of people
look at that and say that this was
actually a terrible that we have
actually one-third of all the cases in
the world
well look I would note this that the
president what he was saying there is
that we are testing when you have more
cases in order to identify those cases
you have to have tested a high volume of
people so the more you test the more
cases numerically not necessarily as a
percent positive but numerically you
will see just by volume sheer volume of
your testing and the president's done an
extraordinary job on this front
Washington Post surveyed governor's
offices and state health departments and
found out at least a dozen
I have testing capacity that outstrips
the supply of patience that's a very
good job done by our federal government
and supporting the states to cite the
governor of New York again quote we have
more sites and more testing capacity
than we're using so we're testing a lot
and thus we're finding a number of cases
but as we safely reopen we do have some
encouraging numbers on that front that
we continue to see a week over week
decline a 15% decline in deaths in just
the last week April 1st to mid-may 50%
decline a new hospitalization and under
25,000 cases today so we are seeing
progress can you tell us what law
specifically the president thinks the
Secretary of State in Michigan broke by
sending out the applications and did the
Secretary of State in Georgia also break
that law by sending out applications for
their fire again I reference you to the
campaign these are ballot questions I
referenced you to the campaign oh yes
the president and my armored mower my
sermon employers the White House so yes
but that's not a campaign question
that's the president the United States
saying that initiatives that you have an
absentee ballot so I would refer you to
the campaign on that front and I would
note to you that many of those ballots
that are submitted via mail can be
fraudulent I cited to the bipartisan
study I can read it again maybe you
weren't paying attention when I read it
the first time so read it again
President Carter a Democrat not a
Republican and James Baker concluded
that these ballots remain the largest
source of potential voter fraud so if
you cast a ballot via mail and you do so
fraudulently that would be an illegal
act and I'd point you to that and for
further I'd point you to my former
employer which is the Trump campaign
yes Thank You Kelly on two questions if
I may firstly on airports the TSA is
reportedly considering setting up
temperature checks at airports given the
numbers of people who can be a
we're sick without a fever do you think
that's sufficient and why was it work
done to have screening at her or sooner
particularly in light of the House
Oversight investigation that called
screening from international hot spots
in March limited statement so the
president is working with TSA he's
working with Airlines we want to ensure
that our TSA employees are safe that
those who are traveling are safe and he
has had those conversations and we are
keeping people safe at the TSA and the
passengers as well over 500 TSA
employees have become sick and six are
dead so again you know do you think this
has been enough action and soon enough
we've taken action we're working with
the TSA we're keeping on America's
essential workers safe and we are
praying for all of those who have been
affected by Corona you know on another
part I wanted to ask about the
president's son and business partner
Eric Trump he recently said a firown'
virus that quote the Democrats are
trying to milk this and predicted it
will quote magically all of a sudden go
away and disappear and everyone will be
able to reopen after the election in
November
do you think Eric Trump's comments are
accurate and also appropriate I think we
all hope coronavirus goes away and I
think as we continue to take the
president his family out of context we
should endeavor to quote them accuracy
and I think we should all hope that the
coronavirus goes we should all look at
the corona virus goes away yes is there
a timeline for when you can't European
Union citizens and visitors are allowed
to come back into the United States and
we'll all European countries be included
or could it be a case-by-case basis so
we don't have a timeline on that just
yet I can tell you the president's
preeminent concern is keeping Americans
safe his travel restrictions have saved
lives as dr. Fauci and others have noted
so we don't have an announcements when
will be rolling those back but his
priority his number one concern is
America first and held them well-being
of the nation first yes thankfully the
associate for governor Whitmer
that she's not planning to meet with
lessons wasn't it good name convocation
tomorrow I wonder if there's a reason
why that it was governor winter with
Mercer in Michigan wasn't extended in
invitation to the president's appearance
in Michigan tomorrow tomorrow and I was
wondering if there's a reason why he
wasn't gonna meet with her like other I
don't think there was a particular
reason I it didn't come up but you know
while I on that note I would point to
governor Whitmer it sounds like she's
curious about an invitation but she
should be quite happy that thanks to
this federal government FEMA obligated
more than two hundred sixteen point two
million dollars to Michigan eight point
six million n95 respirators seven
hundred forty thousand eighteen surgical
masks three hundred eleven thousand five
hundred seventy-one face shields I
should round these up or we'll be here
all day seven hundred sixty thousand
gloves seven hundred ventilators the
president has done quite a bit for
Michigan and her concerns and invitation
but she should be thanking the president
for all the supplies that he's delivered
to her state yes yes Kelly the president
has made clear that he's concerned about
liability issues as companies reopen now
it's the White House engaged with
Republican senators about this issue and
would the president sign another bill
another Kovach bill without liability
being addressed in that so I won't lay
out the president's conditions or lack
thereof for any upcoming legislation he
has mentioned it that it's something
that needs to be looked at closely and
he is looking at closely and he is
discussing with members of the hill
about that but he has made clear in
terms of the face for that he wants to
be slowed as we approach phase four and
not rushed forward with spending
trillions more dollars of taxpayer money
leave we've done a lot so far and he'll
look at doing more in the future and
liabilities definitely something that
he's concerned about him working on
right back there
oh one more on g7 youth do
that would be appropriate to hold a g7
summit in the US while ordinary citizens
are still not allowed to travel freely
for example from Europe yeah you know
the president wants us to start
reopening travel restrictions are
something that you know he wants to make
sure American lives are protected before
those are lifted but that being said I
do think it's entirely appropriate so
does the president have a g7 here
America's reopening the world's
reopening I mean what a show of strength
and optimism to have all of the leaders
of these countries come together at the
White House and pursue business as usual
and as we move forward through this
pandemic is there any one I haven't
gotten to just I guess not
okay so we'll do it we'll do a few more
yeah I had rice roll out there yesterday
in the New York Times it said that
President Trump is counsel to the
president G and also has said that
called his response to the coronavirus
deadly classified as a deadly
mishandling what's the White House's
response to it um so you said that that
came from Susan Rice was it okay so
first I would want to take a moment to
address the president's response because
the president has had an extraordinary
an early response to the corona virus I
would know dr. Burks the early work of
President Trump both the travel
restrictions and quarantine has bought
us the time and space necessary to have
this task force be very effective dr.
Falchi saying that the president's
response has been impressive he can't
imagine under any circumstance that
anyone could be doing anything more I
can go through the actions there's a
detailed timeline out there of January
6th on wuhan issuing a travel travel
notice issued on wuhan when there were
zero cases in the United States the 17th
zero reported US cases and there were
Public Health entry screenings at major
US airports of course the infamous
travel restrictions that were called
xenophobic by Democrats on January 31st
a lot of action in February on
developing a test and making sure we
were moving forward as speedily as
possible on that keep in mind and late
February Pelosi was saying come to
Chinatown it's very safe but the
president
already taken very early action and I
know he brought up Susan Rice in that
context but I'm going to bring her up in
another context that's equally as a new
newsworthy and that is the email that
was Declassified from Susan Rice on
Inauguration Day which is so peculiar
set the scene it's an ovulation day
you're moving out of the White House
this is the most powerful building on
planet earth Susan Rice is moving out
reflecting on her time here and what is
she doing she's not packing her boxes
she's not being nostalgic about her time
in the White House what she's doing is
writing an email worth three times she
writes that President Obama emphasized
to conduct the investigation into
Michael Flynn by the book by the book by
the book she writes that three times as
a Shakespeare said thou doth protest too
much Susan Rice he didn't have the Susan
Rice part in there but I'll add that in
to she was asked specifically about the
unmasking and Michael Flynn after her
after she discussed it on January 5th in
the Oval Office with Obama after she
wrote this email to herself on
inauguration day she was asked by a good
journalist Judy Woodruff about this
email and she said about the unmasking
and Michael Flynn not the email but the
unmasking she was asked specifically
about noon as his claim specifically so
let me clarify was noon as his claim and
she said I know nothing about this so it
was a lie and then Susan Rice stand
still and brought it up to me I will
bring it up to you her attorney said
that this was the first opportunity
three weeks after this oval office
meeting that she had to write this email
memorializing her Oval Office meeting
with a Barack Obama discussing Michael
Flynn it was her first opportunity she
said interesting because she had an
opportunity in those three weeks on
January 10th to do a passing of the
baton event with none other than Michael
Flynn where she praised him wished him
success and talked about the great
transition into the White House and then
on January 12th she was able to
participate in a story that published on
that date in the lifestyle section of
the Washington Post says she never had
time to write this email until
inauguration day as she's rushing out
the door when in fact she had an
opportunity to do all of those things
I'll leave that with you thank you for
bringing up Susan Rice not in the
context
that I wished but for allowing me to
share that